teens over in the Rio Grande Valley they
are now charged with murder this is for
killing a man that they say police
wouldn't do anything about despite
already having warrants for his arrest
are they cold-blooded Killers or were
their actions justified in defense of
their little sister Jonathan Martin
making the case with Attorney Charles
Adams
capital murder because
Quintanilla was kidnapped right when he
was taken and in the back of the F-150
and dropped off somewhere else the story
of two teen Brothers in South Texas
arrested for beating their stepfather to
death for allegedly sexually abusing
their half-sister has a lot of people
talking they were apparently so enraged
that their stepfather Gabriel
Quintanilla they along with their friend
confronted him at a home beat him before
attacking him two more times at another
location reportedly with brass knuckles
then dumping his body in a field where
he was found dead clearly a crime but
was it Justified and as in if you are
the defense attorney in the situation
what you're arguing is that there are
these medicating circumstances the rape
of their very young small child little
sister by their evil stepfather cantonia
did have a warrant out for continual
sexual of another child
I have to ask
how do you have a warrant like that
can't execute it but these kids can find
them it ain't like these kids didn't go
to the authorities because they said the
authorities wasn't doing nothing about
this man and now y'all charging them
with capital murder for not doing your
job this one rubbed me the wrong way a
little bit I asked Attorney Charles
Adams if that history could help a
defense that certainly it it it bolsters
the perception that they were that he
was rightfully accused right because it
was a different victim so now you have
two young children claiming that they
were sexually assaulted by this man
right and if these two brothers and the
friend were aware I think it it provides
a a rationality justification that a lot
of people can understand but the teens
are facing serious charges including
murder and aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon while some might
understand their motivation others argue
killing someone in a situation like this
is never okay but what might a jury say
Charles says while long shot a jury
nullification argument might be the best
option for a defense our U.S lawyer look
at the jury and say hey we understand
that this meets the elements but we're
asking you to find them not guilty
anyway because no one I don't think
there's anyone in America that can't
sympathize with two brothers acting the
way they did in response to someone who
had violently raped their little sister
okay so after reading up on it
essentially what had happened was they
found out about this after the young
young one said something and then they
went over to the RV and beat his ass
then they left then they came back and
then they beat his ass some more
then they loaded him up took his stuff
dropped him off in the field I'm not
from there for death
so
knowing all of these factors
what do you think
I'm not going to say anything insightful
it doesn't have to be that's when
nothing insightful to say
at their eight like even at my age yep
but at their age
who were everything that I was facing
back then you know the the [__] that was
going on and stuff like that
me encountering that
I don't think I would have done um no I
know for a fact I would have done the
same thing
like at that age I was
pissed off
I was pissed off about a lot of things
and if that thing would have happened
on top of everything
I remember there was a situation that
happened
um when I was a kid and um
my dad had to stop me because
a person
was being held as at his Hospital
and I was about to go inside the
hospital with a hammer and
and doing what I had to do
to that guy and my dad stopped me
and it wasn't it for my dad I would have
been there
I would have gone there
I would have been in the same situation
as those guys
those three kids there
I was that guy I was exactly in that
position and I was going there I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you
you shouldn't have done that
I was exactly that kid I just got lucky
that I encountered my dad and he saw
what I had in my backpack he asked me
what the [__] is this and had a
conversation and I was pissed off at my
dad because he stopped me
that was me first year of high school
so
am I gonna tell them that they're wrong
or right or whatever I can't do it
I understand the sentiment
and the risk
but even with that
they're fixing capital punishment which
means life in prison or the death
sentence
teenagers
it's a lot
it's a lot if I'm on a jury like that
you'll have a hard time convincing me
I'm not gonna lie to you
especially when what happened
you have a hard time you're gonna have a
hard [__] time
um
do I think this is right yes I think
it's right I don't know
but it's hard to say it's wrong too
the truth is hard
I'm sorry but I'm not
diddling kids
twice
no no that's two different people it
didn't just happen twice it's two
different people that's two different
people and apparently the first one
happened over the course of a couple
years
now have the cops done their job and
actually caught this man
we be having a different discussion
the justice system fails to apprehend
him he reoffends again then people take
the measure into their own hand
I'm not saying it's the right thing
where you go ah
let these kids go free if you ask me let
them go free I drop all the [__]
charges and some counseling but that's
it I think it's hard to do that as well
because what if it didn't happen I
understand yeah I understand what you're
saying but to me I told you I told you
already I was not gonna say anything
insightful in this [__] video nothing
nothing [__] insightful in this video
don't worry I didn't say anything too
insightful either so you get weed in the
same boat Abba and preach peaches and
cream Peach apple and Peach nothing
inside
so I would I would have said yeah
scot-free and some counseling
that's it
and we'll catch you on the next time
next time you do something to someone
that actually didn't do that you know
what
to the amount of people that watch walks
cut free and stuff like that that's who
you decide to kill
to me
you [__] solve the problem my G
true you did I'm not supposed to even
have this conversation and be like that
I'm supposed to be the bigger person
well you know what [__] that [__] to me
you [__] solved the problem my G
we'll catch you next time if you kill
someone that's really deserved it to me
you have a code of owner [__] that [__]
that's a code of honor the meat on the
simple fact that we're assuming the
man's guilt he may have been in this in
the 2014-2016 and in 2023 we don't know
but we haven't actually charged them
with the crime so to assume that he is
guilty is a stretch now if evidence
comes out showing otherwise and it's
unrefutable then uh you know you got
yourself an ally in me
now but to the lady that lied on them
until Scott got Scott free let them get
caught yeah it's not the same thing I
know I'm saying nothing is going to be
insightful or [__] logical today
that's all right okay all right that's
it for today's video do it again
everybody likes an adventure no no no
don't stop that [__] everybody likes an
Avenger in the movies everybody likes
that [__] right you Revenge everybody
likes the Punisher right because it's
made by Marvel but when it happens in
real life The Punisher and everybody
when it happens in real life you want
capital punishment nah [__] that [__] do
it again
and film it next time